Wir werden sie abonnieren, das heißt ich kündige euch schon alle an. Dann kommt das Intro, dann legen wir los. Ich spüre komplette Begeisterung und das ist die richtige Stimmung. Also dann legen wir los. Die Ligatour ist zurück, wir blicken auf La Liga, die Ligue 1, die Premier League und auch die Serie A mit den Gästen Alexey Mnuch, Christian Bernhard, Alex Troika und in einer eigenen Aufnahme Jogi Hebel.
Heute im Rasenfunk.
Stark, sehr, sehr gut. Und ich hab die Post-Shot-Expected-Ghosts angeguckt. Daher dürfte der Unterschied kommen. Aber in beiden absolut herausragend.
Er ist schon ein bisschen nerdig.
Ja, es gibt schon einen Grund, warum du hier zusammen mit all deinen Kollegen in der Ligatur bist. Es passt halt ganz gut. Rasenfunk und das hier. Ihr ertragt ja auch alle meine Bundesliga-Referenzen. Jetzt werden wir noch einen Helden in Italien besingen. Und dann darfst du direkt einen Moment hinterher schieben, bei dem von Alex Hamberschen eingesammelt wird.
Ja, Ansang, da möchte ich jetzt schonmal Massimiliano Allegri hernehmen. Also der hat ja, wenn wir den besungen haben, dann haben wir den ja monatelang oder jahrelang eher Klagelied-mäßig besungen. Und ja, wir haben es vorhin angesprochen, Juve ist voll im Sol, Juve ist dran. Also nicht nur im Sol, sondern ich würde sogar sagen mehr. Und das hat logisch viel mit Allegri zu tun, weil er es geschafft hat. Ich würde mal sagen, das, was er in seiner ersten Phase bei Juve, was sie ihn ausgemacht hat als Juve-Serienmeister war, als Juve logischerweise auch personell nochmal ganz andere Qualität hatte. Aber Allegri hat es halt immer geschafft, wirklich so ein Zusammengehörigkeitsgefühl, ein Mannschaftsgefühl zu kreieren. Und das ist jetzt dieses Jahr wieder da. Also die letzten zwei Jahre von Allegri hatten wir oft thematisiert, waren enttäuschend, brauchen wir gar nicht drüber reden. Wobei man auch – das letzte Jahr muss man noch dazufügen – er hätte sich eigentlich für die Champions League qualifiziert als Vierter, also sportlich gesehen. Aber jetzt, was er diese Saison macht, es ist wirklich eine extreme Einheit. Wir hatten es thematisiert. Am Anfang diese defensive Stabilität, die ist da. Jetzt wird ein bisschen weiterentwickelt. Und du siehst es halt an vielen kleinen Momenten, zum Beispiel Blauwich und Chiesa, die eigentlich das Einzerpärchen im Sturm sind vom Namen her. Die waren jetzt ganz oft auf der Bank, oder zumindest einer auf der Bank. Und immer, wenn sie reingekommen sind, haben sie funktioniert. Die haben auch von der Bank geliefert. Blauwich hat dieses 2-1 gegen Frosinone von der Bank kommend erzielt. Chiesa hat von der Bank kommend getroffen und Momente kreiert. Und das sind so Zeichen, wo du merkst, die Mannschaft ist ein extrem eingeschworener Haufen. Und da ist Juve gefährlich. Und genau da hat er sie hingebracht. Plus eben, hat man vorhin auch schon angedeutet, diese jungen Elemente mit reingebracht. Yildiz allen voran, Campiaso, auch Gatti, den wir ja auch schon hier thematisiert hatten. Also es scheint, als sei ihm gelungen, dass Juve wirklich diese extreme Juve-Einheit wieder ist. Und wie gesagt, die Tabelle sagt es her. Er ist mittendrin, auch wenn Inter für mich oder für die allermeisten einfach der Favorit bleibt. Aber solange Juve dran ist, wird es unangenehm für Inter sein. Und deshalb finde ich, hat sich das Allegri nach vielen, vielen negativen Dingen absolut mal verdient.
Aber wirklich, Gatti war doch der, der Mauern gebaut hat als Bauarbeiter und dann doch in den Profifußball gekommen ist. Sehr schön. Und was ist dann der Moment der letzten Woche?
Ja, der Moment habe ich mich dafür entschieden. Am vergangenen Spieltag Milan gegen die Roma, was eben das letzte Spiel von Herrn Mourinho war. 3-1 Sieg von Milan, wo Milan wirklich auch wieder gezeigt hat. Sie sind auch wieder auf dem Weg zurück. Sie haben jetzt in den letzten acht Spielen sechs gewonnen, nur eins verloren. Also haben sie dieses Champions League aus verkraftet. Sie sind jetzt klar, der Rückstand zu Inter und Juve ist schon ein bisschen groß. Aber sie haben einen großen Vorsprung auf den Rest. Also sie sind wieder an der Spur. Und es gab das 3-1, wirklich großartiges Tor. Schaut es euch gerne an, falls ihr es noch nicht gesehen habt. Theo Hernandez auf Hackenzuspiel von Olivier Giroud. Hernandez im Lauf, Giroud wunderbar, richtig gelesen, legt ihn in den Lauf. Und Theo Hernandez zimmert ihn unter den Balken, wie man glaube ich so schön sagt. Und ich habe es deswegen auch genommen, nicht nur weil es ein schönes Tor ist, sondern weil es auch bei Milan die letzten Wochen hatten wir auch schon wahnsinnig viele Verletzte, gerade in der Verteidigung. Und deswegen ist Theo Hernandez – jetzt über mehrere Wochen war er Innenverteidiger – hat das eben gut gemacht, weil Milan da unter ihm auch viele Siege jetzt wieder eingefahren hat. Aber jetzt dieses Spiel war jetzt das erste, wo er wieder als Linksverteidiger gespielt hat. Und Theo Hernandez plus Leao zusammen über Links, das hatten wir auch schon ein paar Mal, ist eine gewisse Qualität dahinter. Die hat er jetzt hier wieder gezeigt. Und ein Satz noch, ich glaube, ich habe auch schon ein paar Mal über Giroud gesprochen. Ich muss es jedes Mal wiederholen. Für mich, Giroud, ich glaube, er wird jetzt 37. Also klar, er hat sein Alter. Aber für mich, Giroud weiterhin einer der Spielintelligentesten Neuner, die es gibt. Also es gibt in jedem Spiel, ich habe das Glück, immer wieder Milan Spiele kommentieren zu dürfen, es gibt in jedem Spiel Momente, die nur Giroud durch seinen cleveren Laufweg, durch sein Abschirmen und eben nicht nur das Abschirmen. Ich finde, es gibt viele Mittelstürmer, die gut den Ball abdecken, aber Giroud hat dann halt auch noch diese Kreativität, diesen letzten Pass zu spielen. Und dieses Beispiel hier mit Theo Ananas war perfekt, mit der Hacke, in den Lauf, wunderbar. Also Giroud für mich weiterhin Mittelstürmer Masterclass.
Ach Olivier Giroud, da kommen wir wirklich ins Schwärmen geraten, aus ganz ganz vielen Gründen. Ich danke euch beiden sehr, danke dir, lieber Alex. Und danke dir, lieber Christian. Und dann werde ich mich in wenigen Minuten bedanken bei Jogi Hebel. Mit dem geht es jetzt nämlich weiter. Jogi Hebel ist jetzt hier. Jogi, servus, schön, dass du da bist.
Hallo, grüß dich. Vielen Dank, ich danke für die Einladung.
Ich habe vorhin mit den anderen drüber gesprochen zum Einstieg, wie das eigentlich so ist, wenn man über eine Liga berichtet, die keine Winterpause hat. Das Extrembeispiel war dann gar nicht anwesend. Wie ist denn das so als Reporter? Ich habe mich ja über die paar freien Tage durchaus gefreut, die ich jetzt hatte. Und wie war es bei dir?
Bei uns war jetzt auch so Players Break, nennt man es in England. Da ist dann viel FA Cup und EFL Cup, was für mich dann kein Thema war. Ich persönlich muss sagen, diese Dezemberzeit ist für mich immer die schönste, weil da halt wirklich der volle Fokus auf die Premier League ist. Deswegen würde ich es eher umgekehrt sehen. Ich nehme das dann eher immer als Freudigen an, dass ich sagen kann, okay, da schauen dann wirklich alle und man sieht es dann auch als Highlight. Wenn ich heute ein Spiel habe, dann weiß ich, die Zuschauer werden wahrscheinlich 25 Prozent mehr sein oder wie auch immer. Das heißt, ich habe immer eine schöne Zeit.
Okay, ich sehe schon. Dann bist du trotzdem auch gut erholt, weil du einfach mit guter Laune durch die Arbeit hindurchgerauscht bist. Jetzt haben wir dann logischerweise schon länger nicht mehr über die Premier League gesprochen. Das Tabellenbild nur einmal, damit das kurz erwähnt ist. Liverpool aktuell vorne mit zwei Punkten Vorsprung vor City und vor Villa. Aber Villa hat schon ein Spiel mehr. 45 Punkte Liverpool, 43 City, 43 Eston Villa, dann Arsenal mit 40, Tottenham mit 40 und danach gibt es den Cut. Und alles andere haben wir ja zum Teil schon in der vergangenen Zeit besprochen und werden wir noch besprechen. Heute wollen wir mal blicken auf mögliche Strafen. Und dann werden wir auch nochmal über City sprechen. Was droht denn da schon wieder am Horizont, Jogi?
Ja, das ist eben die große Frage. So genau weiß es noch keiner. Also es ist im Endeffekt nur bestätigt worden, dass für Nottingham Forest und für Everton Strafen drohen, dass sie gegen die Financial Fairplay Regeln der Premier League verstoßen haben. Everton hat das ja schon mal getan. Die haben schon zehn Punkte abgezogen bekommen. Was muss man sagen, eine historische Strafe ist. Wenn wir uns daran erinnern, Portsmouth, die haben mal neun Punkte abgezogen bekommen. Da waren die aber eigentlich insolvent. Also ist es schon eine heftige Strafe. Und jetzt droht ihnen erneut ein Punktabzug, weil eben wieder Verluste eingefahren worden sind. Bei Lothar Hingham genau dasselbe. Da war es irgendwie zu erwarten. Und dann ist natürlich jetzt die ganz große Frage, was passiert? Gibt es wirklich eine Strafe? Gibt es nur eine finanzielle Strafe, dass man nochmal irgendwas zahlen muss? Gibt es wirklich einen Punktabzug? Transfer sperren wir auch immer. Da ist dann alles möglich. Das ist noch nicht so genau klar. Aber es drohen auf jeden Fall Strafen. Das ist klar. Das ist schon so durchgeklungen. Die Frage ist dann einfach nur noch die Höhe. Und dann ist natürlich die Frage, die sich daraus dann dreht. Was passiert mit Chelsea? Was passiert mit Newcastle? Was passiert mit Man City? Kann man das alles vergleichen? Und so weiter und so fort. Also es gibt da Themen ohne Ende momentan. Und vor allem, das haben wir im Podcast auch besprochen, es ist halt super verrückt, dass eigentlich das Land des Turbo-Kapitalismus, die Premier League, die eigentlich so viel Geld ausgeben, wie kaum ein anderes Land in den letzten Jahren, die eigentlich auch so nachlässig waren, wie kaum ein anderes Land, dass die plötzlich hergehen und auf, also wirklich überall hingreifen, wo es nur irgendwie geht. Das persönlich war für uns auch alle neu.
Ja, und gleichzeitig ist ja auch die Frage dann, ob das Instrumentarium, was man sich da zurechtgelegt hat, ob das dann wirklich an den richtigen Stellen eingreift. Also ich habe jetzt auch Diskussionen darüber gelesen. Es geht ja, verkürzt gesagt, korrigiere mich bitte, wenn ich es mir falsch gemerkt habe, aber verkürzt gesagt, geht es darum, du hast eine gewisse Höhe deiner Einnahmen und dementsprechend darfst du nur eine gewisse Menge an Transferausgaben haben. Und wenn du darüber liegst, über einen nennenswerten Zeitraum, da gab es ja noch so drei Kulanzjahre gerade wegen Corona, während Corona, aber dann kann es eben zu Strafen wie eben Punktabzügen kommen. Und da muss man jetzt kein mathematisches Genie sein, um zu sehen, naja, das bevorteilt ja eigentlich erst mal die reichen Clubs, nämlich eben Manchester City und so weiter und so fort, weil die haben eben so viele hohe Einnahmen, dass sie dann sehr viel Spielraum auf der Transferseite haben. Und wir merken es ja jetzt auch, wenn es einen Club wie Nottingham jetzt zum Beispiel treffen würde. Wir alle haben gesehen, was die auf dem Transfermarkt gemacht haben. Also es ist jetzt nicht so, dass die da unschuldig reingerutscht sind. Aber auf der anderen Seite, warum haben sie das denn gemacht? Ja, du steigst auf oder du etablierst dich gerade am unteren Ende der Liga und willst einfach den Abstieg verhindern, der so dramatisch ist aus der Premier League in die Champions League trotz aller Parachute, also falschen Zahlungen. Also es scheint auch so ein bisschen schief zu sein, weil die Teams, wo man eigentlich denken würde, die kann man ja auch mal gerne beschrafen. Manchester City zum Beispiel, werden wir zwar auch gleich noch mal drüber reden, aber so richtig hart trifft die wahrscheinlich dann doch eher wieder nicht.
Genau, absolut. Vor allem habe ich letztens einen sehr interessanten Vortrag gesehen von David Ornstein von Athletic, der genau das beschrieben hat, was du gerade sagst, der es zusammengefasst hat mit. Bei Everton zum Beispiel war es so, die haben über Jahre hinweg Verluste gemacht. Und das Problem ist, sie haben sportlich durch diese Verluste, die sie gemacht haben, keinen Vorteil gehabt. Also zum Beispiel, angenommen sie wären jetzt dritter geworden jedes Mal, dann hätte man gesagt, naja gut, es ist ja wenigstens Wert entstanden. Sportlicher Wert, finanzieller Wert, durch die Spieler wie auch immer. Dann hätte man mehr Nachsicht walten lassen, als wenn man sagt, naja gut, die Strugglen hat einfach jedes Jahr, da sind die kurzer vorab zu steigen, die wollen noch mal alles raushauen, um in der Liga zu bleiben, um die Einnahmen zu garantieren. Das wird denen dann als Nachteil oder als negativ ausgelegt, dass sie dann strampeln quasi im Endeffekt. Und das macht es dann irgendwie auch noch mal verrückter, dass dann Everton noch mehr bestraft wird, weil sie eben sagen, wir wollen unbedingt in der Liga bleiben. Das ist sehr, sehr verrückt insgesamt das Ganze.
Ja, wobei andererseits kann man da natürlich auch argumentieren, genau bei solchen Clubs passieren dann die finanziell richtigen Dramen, weil du eben dann versuchst, den Abstieg zu verhindern und dann steigst du dennoch ab. Ich meine, da haben wir genügend Beispiele aus allen Ligen, dass das das ist, was einen ganzen Verein killen kann. Und das haben wir ja tatsächlich in der Premier League auch schon erlebt, bzw. in den unteren Ligen. Da haben wir ja mal diese Sonderfolge zu Bolton gemacht, zu Almeria und der dritte Case fällt mir gerade nicht mehr ein. Aber da sind quasi innerhalb von wenigen Wochen Vereine quasi einfach letztlich komplett aus dem Vereinsregister gelöscht worden, muss noch mal ganz unten wieder anfangen. Also es ergibt schon irgendwie Sinn, regulativ einzugreifend. Andererseits finde ich es aber auch ein bisschen schwer, dass aktuell zumindest immer noch so schwierig abzuschätzen ist, was jetzt passiert. Also wir haben die Everton den Punktabzug, wenn euch das interessiert, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, das war die Ligatour vom 30.11. Da hat Hendrik Buchheister damals auch darüber gesprochen. Ja, ein bisschen wirkt das auch so, als soll da jetzt ein Exempel statuiert werden und eben gezeigt werden, so, jetzt greifen wir richtig durch. Wenn das jetzt bei Nottingham und nochmal Everton wieder so ist, okay, dann etabliert sich so langsam Maßstab. Aber es ist sehr schwer, irgendwie abzuschätzen, was da jetzt passiert, was eben die mögliche Höhe der Strafe angeht.
Absolut, das ist das eine Ding. Und auf der anderen Seite, wir kriegen ja dann logischerweise auch Zuschriften bei Instagram, wie auch immer, oder auch bei Twitter. Und die erste Reaktion war halt, das ist jetzt völlig fern von jeder Realität, von irgendwelchen Ermessensspielräumen. Aber du kriegst natürlich sofort, ja, dann bin ich gespannt, was mit Newcastle passiert. Ja, dann bin ich gespannt, was mit Chelsea passiert. Ja, dann bin ich gespannt, was mit City passiert. Das kannst du alles nicht vergleichen. Aber du kannst dem Fan halt auch nicht verkaufen. Everton und Nottingham kriegen es ab. Und die anderen kriegen momentan erst mal gar nichts. Und das ist halt das große, das ist das, was die Diskrepanz nicht meinte, dass diese kleinen Vereine, dass der Fan da draußen das Gefühl bekommt, die kleinen Vereine bekommen es ab. Und City bekommt irgendwie 100.000 Euro Strafe, und dann ist das Ding weg. Nochmal, diese Fälle kann man nicht vergleichen. Jeweils nicht vergleichen. Das ist jetzt alles nicht derselbe Tatbestand. Aber das muss, glaube ich, der Zuschauer draußen, der jetzt vielleicht meistens La Liga schaut, vielleicht der dann auch einmal auf die Premier League schaut, der muss das nicht verstehen. Und dann zum Beispiel, wenn man dann den ganz großen Bogen zieht auf andere Vereine wie Barcelona, die Schulden haben ohne Ende, da passiert dann nichts und so weiter und so fort. Also das kann man dann auch auf den europäischen Kosmos ausweiten. Dass jetzt plötzlich in der Premier League, die auch jahrelang überall weggeschaut haben, jetzt wird zugegriffen, in anderen Ländern wird nicht zugegriffen, in der Bundesliga zum Beispiel, sind sie verhältnismäßig immer schon streng, dann aber wieder, naja, gut, es gibt einen Gnadengesuck und so weiter. Es ist einfach alles halt irgendwie so ein bisschen verrückt. Wer wann wo wieves halt warum. Und das ausgerechnet die Premier League jetzt so zu packt, das ist halt wirklich komplett neu.
Ja, ich meine, grundsätzlich finde ich das mal sehr interessant, wenn da eben mal genauer drauf geguckt wird. Aber eben du sagst es, es ist nicht zu vergleichen. Also Barca hat zwar Schulden ohne Ende, Barca hat aber halt auch die Gewinne der nächsten zehn Jahre verkaufen können. Und es ist sehr richtig anzunehmen, dass die wahrscheinlich auch Gewinne haben werden. Und das ist etwas anderes, wenn das zum Beispiel Everton machen würde. Wenn die die Gewinne der nächsten zehn Jahre verkaufen und dann aber absteigen, dann beginnen nämlich die richtigen Probleme. Und Newcastle zum Beispiel ist ein gutes Beispiel. Also ich bin zahlender Kunde bei Swiss Rumble. Das ist ja Kieran McGuire, der immer – nee, nicht McGuire, nein, Kieran heißt auf jeden Fall mit Vornamen – der so die Wirtschaftsberichterstattung auf so ein neues Level gehoben hat. Und gerade bei der Premier League sind die Artikel immer ellenlang. Den zu Newcastle habe ich auch nicht komplett gelesen, ich gebe es zu. Den zu Nottingham Forest jetzt gerade auch nur nochmal ganz schnell überflogen, damit ich im Thema bin. Aber der arbeitet das dann immer sehr genau raus. Und da siehst du dann aber eben auch, so jemand wie Newcastle hat einen größeren Spielraum. Es ist nicht vergleichbar zur Everton-Situation, nicht vergleichbar zur Nottingham-Position, wird aber sehr wahrscheinlich auch bei Newcastle zu marken sein, weil das Financial Fairplay bezieht sich immer auf die letzten drei Jahre. Das heißt, Newcastle kam von einem relativ guten Fundament, haben dann ihre großen Ausgaben gehabt. Und er kommt eben hier zu dem Fazit, was Newcastle angeht. Also die werden sehr sicher Spieler verkaufen müssen. So werden die nicht weitermachen können. Das heißt, es ist was, was in der Zukunft liegt. Das heißt, man kann es auch immer erst im Rückblick dann mit mehreren Jahren Abstand eigentlich bewerten. Und das macht es aber schwierig für uns. Und das ist eben jetzt Everton und Nottingham. Bei Everton kommt ja noch das Thema mit dazu, dass Triple Seven die kaufen möchte. Triple Seven hat jetzt gesagt, bis Ende Januar soll das durch sein. Das ist auch so ein komischer Prozess, dass man gar nicht so genau weiß, wann prüft die Premier League das, wann sind sie denn jetzt endlich fertig mit ihrer Prüfung. Erlebst du das auch als so ein bisschen, man tappt da ständig im Nebel?
Ja, aber die Schwierigkeit ist halt eben das, da ist vielleicht auch dann die Brücke zu City, dass dieser Nebel ja nicht unbedingt von der Premier League verschuldet ist, sondern teilweise von den Vereinen auch. Weil zum Beispiel, Everton hat ja den ersten Punktabzug bekommen, weil sie es zugegeben haben. Sie haben gesagt, wir haben das getan, hier sind unsere Papiere, schaut mal rein. Das und das haben wir falsch gemacht, da haben wir zu viel ausgegeben. Wir haben das auch erkannt, deswegen haben wir zum Beispiel Anthony Gordon verkauft, hätten wir sonst vielleicht nicht gemusst, hätten wir sonst vielleicht nicht getan. Also das heißt, wir haben das erkannt, wir geben das zu, wir wüssten, wir würden sonst eine höhere Strafe kriegen, wir geben es zu, bitte bestraft und jetzt sanfter in Anführungszeichen. Dementsprechend ist dieser Case abgeschlossen mit den zehn Punkten. City zum Beispiel sagt, wir haben nichts getan, wir wissen überhaupt nicht, wovon ihr redet. Wenn ihr etwas gegen uns erhebt an Vorwürfen, dann tut das bitte, aber uns geht das nichts an. Dementsprechend zieht sich das länger. Dementsprechend denkt der Zuschauer draußen aber, City wird nicht bestraft. Nur die Kleinen trifft es immer. Das ist halt auch die Diskrepanz an den ganzen Geschichten, dass manche halt mitarbeiten und manche halt nicht. Und Everton dachte, sie würden verhältnismäßig sanfter vorkommen, bekommen dann aber die zehn Punkte hingeklatscht und kriegen sie jetzt vielleicht nochmal. Und dann kommt natürlich diese Fallhöhe wieder dazu, dass dann alle sagen, naja, wenn Everton zehn Punkte bekommt, City aber 115 Anklagepunkte hat, dann sind wir mal gespannt, was da passiert. Jetzt, wenn aber dann rauskommt, bei City, ja, das war ein und derselbe Tatbestand, 73 Mal und dann noch ein anderer und die kriegen zwei Punkte abgezogen oder vielleicht eine Strafe von einer Million. Mach mal 20, mach mal 10, ist ja egal wieviel. Dann wird der Zuschauer wieder sagen, ich kann das nachvollziehen. Du kannst alles, du kannst die Sachen nicht vergleichen. Du kannst auch dann im Endeffekt die Tatbestände nicht vergleichen. Du kannst auch die Strafen dann logischerweise nicht vergleichen. Und das macht es halt dann wieder so schwierig. Im Endeffekt nehme ich da nicht raus, wenn ich die Berichte nicht lese oder nicht eben mit David Ons den anhöre, sondern eben einfach nur von draußen auf das ganze Blick gedehnke ich mir auch. Ja klar, die Kleine erwischt es wieder. Das ist ja in der Champions League genau selbe gewesen. Der FC Sion wird ausgeschlossen, bei City heißt es, ach zahlt uns und das Ganze wird unter den Tisch gekehrt. Das ist halt dann immer dieser fahre Beigeschmack, der bleibt halt irgendwo immer und das ist dann vielleicht auch rational gar nicht zu erklären.
Und glaubst du, was eben jetzt die Anklage von Manchester City angeht, dass das noch in dieser Saison entschieden wird?
Also es heißt, was man so liest, oder es kam gestern der Bericht, dass eine Anhörung jetzt angesetzt ist. Das heißt in nächster Zeit. Es steht nicht genau das Datum, aber man geht davon aus, was ich jetzt gelesen habe, Ende Februar, dass City mal gehört wird. Und dann ist natürlich auch die Frage, was sagen die? Also alles, was sie jetzt gesagt haben, die City Group, war so quasi, wir wissen überhaupt nicht, wovon ihr redet. Und das ist halt dann wieder ein Zeichen dafür, dass sich das eher noch mal ziehen könnte. Verjährt dann was, verschleiert sich irgendwas, kriegen die irgendwie die Möglichkeit, irgendwas zu verschleiern. Das ist dann wieder die Frage, die man sich stellen muss. Und dann ist natürlich auch, das ist dann wirklich Zukunftsmusik, aber Guardiola sagte, wenn ihr mich angelogen habt, also die Citigroup, wenn ihr mich angelogen habt und ihr habt doch etwas getan, dann bin ich weg. Weil er hat sich hingestellt und hat gesagt, mir wurde erzählt, es ist nichts passiert, es ist nichts getan worden, was irgendwie falsch war. Dementsprechend habe ich hier ein reines Gewissen, sollten die mich angelogen haben, dann bin ich weg. Das hat er öffentlich gesagt. Auch das ist natürlich Zukunftsmusik, aber es ist sehr interessant dann zu sehen, wie würde Pep Guardiola reagieren, wenn wirklich rauskäme, City hat sich falsch verhalten. City bekommt einen Punktabzug, bekommt eine fette Strafe. Sie waren es dann doch, oder wie auch immer. Das ist dann natürlich die große Frage, was passieren würde.
Na gut, wir haben gerade im La Liga-Segment gehört, Xavi wackelt bei Barca. Das könnte ja dann vielleicht was sein. Aber jetzt warten wir erstmal ab, und ob das Ganze ja vielleicht dann auch ins Titelrennen eingreift. Also es ist auch für die Premier League nicht so einfach, muss man auch zugeben. Also wir haben jetzt hier, glaube ich, ein paar valide Kritikpunkte gemacht. Ich möchte allerdings auch nicht derjenige bei der Premier League sein, der eben nach Jahrzehnten des Wegguckens jetzt anfangen muss, da Maßstäbe zu etablieren.
Das ist super schwierig. Und bei City muss man ganz kurz noch einen Satz, weil bei Everton, du hast es ja vorher gesagt, es waren Verluste, die die gemacht haben, die haben zu viel Geld ausgegeben und so weiter. Bei City ist es ja was anderes. Da war es jetzt nicht zu viel Geld, sondern es wurden Sponsorenverträge zu hoch angesetzt im Vergleich zum Marktstandard. Sie haben Spielerverträge zu hoch angesetzt, die aber nicht bekannt gegeben oder nicht ausgewiesen in ihren Bilanzen. Das sind auch ein paar Jugendspieler. Dann wurde, glaube ich, an Roberto Mancini eine Sonderzahlung geleistet, die nirgends aufgetreten ist. Solche Dinge waren es. Es ist jetzt nicht vergleichbar mit Everton. Das ist genau das, was ich meine. David Ornstein meint zum Beispiel auch, das finde ich sehr interessant, der Tatbestand trat irgendwie keine Ahnung, wie oft auf. Also Jack Wheelish, blablabla. Also mehrere Spieler. Und dann ist die Frage, wenn du ein Vergehen 70 mal machst, ob das dann schwerwiegender ist, als ob du 70 verschiedene machst. Das ist dann die Frage. Das können wir alle nicht einschätzen, wie die Premier League darauf reagiert. Ob die sagen, naja, die haben den Fehler 70 mal gemacht, ist egal. Jetzt haben wir es ihnen ja gesagt, beim 71. Mal wird es nicht passieren. Keine Ahnung, ob es dann doch passiert. Aber das ist dann die Frage, die dann die Premier League auch zu beantworten hat.
Also wir werden ganz sicher darüber noch sprechen. Wir werden aber auch sportlich noch über City sprechen. Und das hat unter anderem mit einem Mann zu tun, den wir schon häufig in der Ligatur besprochen haben oder erwähnt haben. Und in den letzten Wochen aber nicht, weil er verletzt war. Und das ist Kevin de Bruyne. Der ist zurück und nicht ganz so schlecht, dass er wieder zurück ist, oder?
Es war unfassbar. Ich hab das Spiel gemacht, Newcastle gegen Man City. Und es war wirklich, also Newcastle hat geführt zu dem Zeitpunkt. Kevin de Bruyne kommt rein mit neuer Frisur, sehr schick und macht einfach ein, ich kann es wirklich nur jedem ans Herz legen, das sich nochmal anzusehen. Das Highlight, weil er macht ein Tor, das wirklich eigentlich eher ein langer Ball ist. Er sieht genau, wenn ich jetzt dort den Ball so irgendwie reinschneide, was eher wirklich aussieht wie ein langer Ball in die Spitze, durch die Beine des Gegenspielers ins lange Eck, dann könnte der reingehen. Und er geht genau durch die Beine, er geht genau in die Ecke. Es ist wirklich perfekt getimt alles, es ist perfekt ausgeguckt. Unglaublich. Und dann am Schluss diese Flanke auf Oskar Bob, der den Ball natürlich auch perfekt mitnimmt, verwertet. Das ist sagenhaft. Aber dass er ihn auch sieht. Also City hat davor riesengroße Probleme gehabt. Also die ersten 70 Minuten waren Symptome der ganzen Saison. Dass sie ja, sie haben den Ball, ja, aber wenn dann Harlan auch noch fehlt und sie wirklich darauf angewiesen sind, irgendetwas zu kreieren, haben sie Probleme momentan, dann kommt die Beune und zeigt, Jungs, so geht es eigentlich. Und das war wirklich, glaube ich, das, ich habe es eben im Spiel gesagt, auch das ist ja schon eigentlich kitschig, das immer wieder zu sagen, aber es ist so, dieses Ende war so kitschig, keiner hätte gedacht, oder jeder hätte gedacht, wenn du ein Buch schreiben müsstest, schreib es so, der Beune kommt rein, macht ein Tor, macht eine Vorlage, alle jubeln. Und genauso kam es. Es musste einfach genauso sein. Es musste genauso sein.
Mit dem Siegtreffer eben in der 91. Minute. Und deswegen bleibt eben City an Liverpool dran. Arsenal und Tottenham, die haben schon fünf Punkte Rückstand auf die absolute Spitze. Ist es fair zu sagen, das Titelrennen wird zwischen den oberen drei entschieden, mit natürlich Aston Villa als krassen Außenseiter? Oder wie weit, würdest du sagen, geht denn der Bereich der Tabelle, aus dem der Titelträger kommen könnte?
Ich würde die schon noch mitnehmen, ehrlich gesagt. Also sie ist ja auch irgendwie – gestern habe ich wieder gelesen – Gary Neville sagt, Tottenham kann noch mit eingreifen und so. Also ich würde die allesamt nicht rausnehmen, weil wir eine Sache gelernt haben in dieser Saison. Immer wenn wir denken, eine Mannschaft hat es jetzt gerafft, jetzt sind die raus aus der Geschichte, dann verlieren die wieder. Also alle haben gesagt, Arsenal wird Meister. Die haben momentan die beste Phase. Jetzt brechen die komplett weg.
Zwei Niederlagen, ein Unentschieden in den letzten drei Spielen.
Dann dachten alle, City ist weg. Ich glaube, die waren fünf Spiele sieglos zwischendrin mal. Jetzt sind die wieder komplett da und alle sagen, es wird sowieso wieder City. Liverpool hat am Anfang keiner auch nur irgendetwas gesehen in denen. Jetzt plötzlich sind die ganz oben. Jetzt gibt es aber schon wieder die ersten, die sagen, gegen City können die nicht mithalten. Es ist momentan Tottenham. Die ersten zehn Spiele ungeschlagen. Dann plötzlich gab es eine Serie, weil ein paar Verletzte waren. Das ist wirklich das, was wir gelernt haben. In dieser Saison kann man es nicht sagen. Das macht mir am meisten Spaß, dass da oben nicht zwei weglaufen, nicht einer wegläuft, sondern dass alle Probleme haben und dass es spannend werden oder bleiben kann. Sagen wir mal, mindestens bis März.
Ja gut, wobei du hast mir doch mal erzählt, dass Manchester City im März und April nicht mehr verliert. Haben wir da nicht drüber geredet? Als City seine Schwächephase in der Hinrunde hatte, hast du gesagt, also hatten sie nicht. Und hast du gesagt, normalerweise haben sie jetzt immer die Schwächephase.
Man muss sich schön saufen. Ich hoffe wirklich, dass es spannend bleibt. Ich schlafe nicht in Vereinsbettwäsche, aber auch du weißt das am allerbesten. Aus der Heimat, das tut einfach gut, wenn mal ein anderer Meister werden würde. Das täte gut.
Ja, das ist allerdings wahr. Und die Geschichten sind halt auch dann einfach andere. Hast du das Gefühl, dass die Arbeit von Jürgen Klopp fair bewertet wird? Ich habe das Gefühl, dass man in der kritischen Phase von Liverpool viel mehr über Liverpool und eben sein Team gelesen hat, als jetzt in den letzten Wochen, wo es ja wirklich einfach zum Teil fantastisch war.
Ja, das ist halt auch ein deutsches Phänomen. Also ich habe dieses Interview mit Thomas Tuchel zum Beispiel auch gehört. Er sagt, die Deutschen sind halt einfach so. Also in Deutschland wird er immer anders wahrgenommen als auf der Insel. Aber man muss eine Sache auch sagen. Das ist jetzt auch wirklich nur eine Beobachtung. Jürgen Klopp ist halt auch ein, ich sag mal, lauter Charakter. Also im Sinne von er sagt halt auch Dinge, er eckt an mit seinen Sachen, er hält auch nicht hinterm Berg mit seinen Emotionen, sondern der sagt mal hier was, der sagt mal da was. Er ist manchmal jetzt auch nicht der allerbeste Verlierer, ehrlich gesagt, wenn irgendwas gegen ihn geht. Klar, sagt er ja eigentlich auch, dass er gar nicht so gut ist. Oder wenn man ein Spiel nicht so gut hat, oder wenn er irgendwas als ungerecht empfindet. Und das polarisiert auf der Insel halt auch mittlerweile. Also am Anfang fanden das alle superwitzig. Mittlerweile merke ich schon, dass auch der eine oder andere sich abnutzt an ihm. Und das ist, glaube ich, eher so der Punkt. Insgesamt, glaube ich, hat sich bei ihm jetzt wenig verändert. Vorausschreit natürlich immer schon diese, auch bei ihm so dieser Punkt. Manchmal sind mir die englischen Medien ein bisschen zu hart. Ein bisschen zu, teilweise auch wirklich zu boulevardesque. Und das, glaube ich, nervt ihn schon auch. Also das ist einfach so ein Abnutzungskampf, der immer voranschreitend ist.
Ja, also das, glaube ich, kann man definitiv sagen, wenn man sich beschäftigt mit eben Tränen in der Premier League. Es ist, glaube ich, noch mehr als in anderen Ligen ein krasser Abnutzungskampf. Weil einfach die Art der Berichterstattung eine andere ist, die Art der öffentlichen Wahrnehmung eine andere ist. Und du auch eben ganz andere Themen hast in der Premier League. Die Erwartungshaltung ist logischerweise eine andere. Und die Liga ist eine komplett andere als alle anderen Top-Ligen, über die wir so sprechen.
Die Journalisten, muss man auch sagen, sind natürlich auch weiter weg. Also zum Beispiel, wenn ich mal mit einem Journalisten telefoniert aus England, dann habe ich gesagt, wir haben die Nummer von Daniel Fahke. Dann hieß es, wie, ihr habt die Nummer von Daniel Fahke? Das geht ja gar nicht. Bei uns hat die keiner, also keiner darf mit dem sprechen. Das gibt es ja gar nicht. Und wir würden uns niemals trauen, mit dem zu sprechen. Na gut, wir telefonieren eigentlich mit den Trainern immer vor jedem Spiel. Das gibt es gar nicht. Dementsprechend sind die so weit weg. Es gibt kein öffentliches Training. Die müssen irgendwo auch Quellen, so Drittquellen vertrauen. Wenn die dann Quatsch erzählen, das ist jetzt nicht unbedingt hundertprozentig stimmt, dann kann ich schon verstehen, dass ein Jürgen Klop sich auch mal hinsetzt und sagt, wo habt ihr denn den Mist jetzt wieder her? Auf der anderen Seite, er spricht halt auch nicht mit den Leuten. Weil es dann einfach in Englern so ist, das ist dann auch ein Teufelskreis. In Deutschland haben wir dann den großen Vorteil, für die Trainer mal einen Nachteil, dass wir ein paar Interne mehr wissen als der englische Journalist. Die sind da verhältnismäßig neidisch auf uns.
Ja, gut. Das kann ja auch ein Vorteil für die Trainer sein. Ich meine, wir zwei haben da schon so oft über Themen aus der Bundesliga geredet, wo du weißt, wenn ein Trainer dir etwas einordnet, vorher im Gespräch, bevor du in den Kommentar gehst, dann kannst du da ganz anders drüber sprechen. Und ich weiß verbrieft von vielen, vielen Beispielen, wo eben ein möglicherweise sehr kritisch anzunehmendes Thema gar nicht so kritisch dann live berichtet wurde, weil man ein paar Hintergründe dazu erfahren hat und dann eben gesehen hat, aha, so und so scheint das zu sein. Merke ich mir mal für den Hinterkopf. Und dann kommt irgendwann der sehr interessante Effekt. Das habe ich natürlich nicht, weil ich nicht mit den Trainern spreche, aber jemand wie du, du sprichst halt dann mit verschiedenen Trainern über den gleichen Spieler. Und wenn dann irgendwann sich quasi beim dritten Trainer Geschichten wiederholen oder eben Einschätzungen zu diesem Spieler, dann macht das ja auch deinen Job total wertvoll, weil dann kann man sich wirklich so halbwegs sicher sein, okay, gut, also dieser Spieler scheint außerhalb des Platzes ungefähr in diese Kategorie zu fallen. Also man kann es ja auch für sich nutzen. Ich verstehe, warum die Kultur da eine andere ist in der Premier League. Ist ja auch historisch gewachsen und so weiter, aber…
Genau, aber ich kann Jürgen Klopp da natürlich schon verstehen, wenn irgendwie berichtet wird, keine Ahnung, jetzt nehmen wir mal das Beispiel Kylian Mbappé, die sind sehr fortgeschritten, hieß es mal irgendwie. Und er sagt, wir haben mit dem gar nicht gesprochen, wo kommt denn der Mister? Dann kann ich schon verstehen, dass der vielleicht irgendwann mal sagt, das ist der 15. Fehlbericht von euch, was soll denn das? Kann ich dann schon verstehen. Und das wiederum nehmen die Medien dann auf, nehmen das persönlich, denken sich, was soll der Quatsch jetzt? Schreiben dann beim nächsten Mal wieder so und so, weil sie eben nicht mehr wissen, weil einfach die Kultur eine andere ist. Sie irgendwie aus der Ferne irgendwas einschätzen müssen, irgendwie zu sich zusammenklöppeln müssen. Und dann sieht es halt so aus. Also ich kann beide Seiten komplett verstehen. Macht es halt, glaube ich, in Englern auch nicht einfach. Wie gesagt, mit einem reden wir sehr, sehr häufig zu Chelsea. Der sagt immer, meine Quellen sagen. Also er selbst weiß es oftmals nicht, sondern er hat immer irgendjemand im Busch sitzen. Das ist aber das Einzige.
Und es wird natürlich aber halt auf Dauer auch nicht besser, wenn du dich dem komplett verschließst. Also Jürgen Klopp, er hat dann mal irgendwie ein über 2-stündiges Interview gegeben bei Matze Hischer im Hotel Matze. Aber er sagt dann selber im Interview, dass ich jetzt hier sitze, hat wesentlich damit zu tun, dass du dich null für Fußball interessierst und dich da auch überhaupt nicht auskennst. Auf der einen Seite total legitim, auf der anderen Seite denkt man sich aber auch, ja, man könnte sich aber auch jetzt, es gibt ja unterschiedliche Fußballmedien, da könnte man sich, wenn Jürgen Klopp bei euch sehr ist, bei Click & Rush, da würde er ein ganz anderes Interview führen. Vielleicht würde ihm auch die eine oder andere Frage nicht gefallen. Aber er könnte wahrscheinlich auch sehr, sehr viele Missverständnisse oder Ungenauigkeiten aus dem Weg räumen.
Ja, bestes Gegenbeispiel, wir hatten jetzt letztens bei Rondo Christian Eichner. Ich meine, das ist natürlich eine ganz andere Fallhöhe. Aber der setzt sich halt hin und antwortet auf alles. Also wir konnten den alles fragen und der weiß auch wie, also da brauchen wir uns ja auch nicht. Jürgen Klopp ist intelligent genug und auch gewandt genug, um selbst wenn ich ihm eine ASI-Frage stelle, in Anführungszeichen eine harte Frage, wo ich wirklich sage, was haben Sie denn taktisch da? Der weiß doch, wie er da rauskommt. Also das ist jetzt nicht das Ding. Aber ich will ihn jetzt auch nicht irgendwie in die Pfanne hauen, im Sinne von er muss mehr mit den Medien. Ich glaube, der macht schon genug. Ich habe das ja letztens auch mal mitgesehen. Ich musste mal nach dem Spiel ein Interview mit ihm führen, in der Mixed Zone. Ich musste schon eine Stunde warten, bis der kam. Aber nicht, weil der keinen Bock hatte oder so, sondern weil der halt schon mit 10.000 anderen Stationen reden musste. Also ich kann es schon verstehen, dass dem das irgendwann auch mal zum Hals raushängt. Die 15. Pressekonferenz, zum 15. Mal dieselbe Frage. Dann ist ein Journalist drei Wochen nicht da, in der vierten Woche kommt er dann wieder, stellt ihm dann wieder eine Frage, die er schon 13 Mal beantwortet hat. Dann teilweise mit einem falschen Kontext und so weiter und so fort. Also ich kann das schon auch verstehen. Ja, am Ende sind wir alle Profis oder sollten es sein, ist er auch. Aber dass irgendwann mal eine Antwort rauskommt, die jetzt nicht jeden streichelt, kann ich komplett nachvollziehen. Und da bin ich auch wirklich voll auf seiner Seite. Und ehrlich gesagt, es gibt auch teilweise Fragen. In der Vorbereitung schaue ich mir die Pressekonferenzen ja auch immer an. Es gibt manchmal Fragen, da denkst du dir als Journalist auch, sag mal, wie kann man so eine Frage stellen? Das weiß jeder da draußen, der ein Premier League Spiel gesehen hat, weiß es besser und würde diese Frage nicht stellen. Deswegen manchmal ist es schon auch irgendwie so. Und manchmal wollen die auch wirklich bei Schlagzeilen provozieren bei ihm. Das muss man auch ganz klar sagen.
Ja, und gleichzeitig, ach, ich würde das mal so gerne begleiten, einen Trainer und unter anderem eben bei diesem Interviewmarathon. Weil ich glaube, man macht sich da wirklich keine Vorstellung, gerade bei Topspielen, wie lange die noch unterwegs sind. Also für die Spieler ist es vorbei, für die Trainer beginnt dann nochmal anderthalb Stunden, zwei Stunden brutale Arbeit.
Und die müssen ja immer dieselbe Frage, weil jeder Journalist hat die gleiche, ist ja ganz normal, wie oft Pep Guardiola nach Kevin de Bruyne gefragt werden muss nach diesem Spiel. Das ist ganz normal, also das ist ja irre.
Und das ist ja immer etwas Positives. Das ist ja keine Fehlinterleitung des Schiedsrichters oder so.
Aber es ist vor dem Spiel genau dasselbe gewesen. Auch da haben wir manchmal Einblicke, wenn du siehst, die gehen von einem Mikrofon zum anderen und die gleiche Frage wird gestellt. Ja, warum? Ich weiß gar nicht, was es war bei Eddie Howe. Ah genau, Joel Linton fehlt. Und der gibt halt einfach, bei drei Stationen muss er die gleiche Antwort geben. Also es nimmt sich nicht aus dem Pool, sondern er sagt halt immer, that Joel Linton is missing, is very hard for us, blablabla. Und er sagt dann halt in fünf verschiedenen Wortlauten, er sagt das an fünf Stationen und danach denkst du dir auch, also es ist wirklich Wahnsinn. Deswegen kann ich schon verstehen, dass wenn der Jürgen Klopp zum 15. Mal gefragt wird, warum kommt Kiel an den Papet? Dummes Beispiel, aber weil es wahrscheinlich wirklich sehr polarisierend ist, dass der irgendwann mal beim sechsten Mal sagt, also jetzt kann ich es echt nicht mehr hören, wie sollen wir denn die 700 Millionen für den Kameraden auftreiben? Also ich kann es schon nachvollziehen. Und dann wird eben wieder eine Aussage von vor 13 Jahren um die Ohren gehauen, ja sie haben mal gesagt, sie haben kein Geld, jetzt haben sie aber Geld. Dann denkst du dir, ja, es hat sich halt ein paar Sachen ver… Ich kann es nachvollziehen, dass man dann irgendwann mal sagt, also jetzt kann ich es nicht mehr hören. Ich kann es, glaube ich, ich kann es mir vorstellen.
Genau und auf der anderen Seite, das nur zum Abschluss dieses Sondersegments gerade, ist aber ja auch die Aufgabe des Fragestellers oder der Fragestellerin, die offensichtlichen Fragen zu stellen. Du stehst nicht da, um dich zu verkünsteln, sondern du musst nach den drei großen Aufregern fragen. Und das ist auch undankbar. Und auch Journalistinnen und Journalisten müssen das lernen dürfen. Im Pressekonferenz, man darf auch mal eine dumme Frage stellen. Und ich hatte zum Beispiel mal Kontakt mit demjenigen, der mal Jürgen Klopp eine Frage gestellt hat und ihn gebeten hat, dass er keine Flosken in der Antwort verwendet. Da hat Jürgen Klopp ihn komplett eingesagt. Und das war – Hat dich auch schon? Etwas frech formuliert. Aber das kann so eine Journalistenkarriere auch ganz schnell ein Stoppschild dran machen. Da war nämlich dann mit, du gehst jetzt nicht mehr zur Pressekonferenz. Und wenn ich mich gerade richtig erinnere, ist er auch nämlich seitdem nicht mehr im Sport unterwegs gewesen, sondern musste sich ein anderes Feld suchen. Weil einfach eine etwas zu forsch- oder unglücklich formulierte Frage, er hatte es nicht ganz so gemeint, wie es ankam. Und dann eben die entsprechende Reaktion von Klopp dafür gesorgt hat, dass die komplette Redaktion gesagt hat, okay, du bist im Grunde raus. Also es ist auch auf der anderen Seite des Balles oder des Mikrophones nicht so.
Ich hatte das mal mit Arsene Wenger. Ich weiß noch, es war meine erste Pressekonferenz und ich wollte da unbedingt mit. Wenn Arsene Wenger in Dortmund ist, da wollte ich unbedingt mit. Für Skysport News war ich damals im Volo-Austausch, weiß ich noch. Und ich trottel, Stelldeben hat einfach, da war Serge Nabry damals so zwei, drei Spiele mal gemacht in der Premier League, musste aushelfen, mehr oder minder. Und dann war halt die Option, er könnte in der Champions League vielleicht auch spielen gegen Dortmund. Ich wollte ihm die Frage stellen, ist das eine Möglichkeit? Und ich trottel, Stelldeben, super klug wie ich bin, einfach eine geschlossene Frage. Ist es eine Möglichkeit, dass Serge Nabry im Kader ist? Und Arsene Wenger schaut mich an und sagt, ja. Und alle lachen natürlich in dem Raum und ich denke mir, du voll trottel, ey. Du hast Journalistik studiert, du hast und so weiter. Und 10.000 Interviews und du hast alles in der Theorie. Und dann stellst du dem eine geschlossene Frage, du Holzkopf. Und der war dann aber so cool, als er gesagt hat, der hat das kurz abgewartet, hat sich diesen Lacher geholt und hat dann aber geantwortet, yes, Serge Nabry is a great player, blablabla. Und das war dann so, Gott sei Dank, wir haben die Antwort bekommen. Und ich stehe jetzt nicht ganz. Aber in dem Moment, dann Stefan Schäuble war damals der Kollege, der sagte, na hast du es gemerkt, es ist doch nicht so einfach. Wenn du sitzt da, denkst du, in einem normalen Gespräch würde der antworten. Auf einer Pressekonferenz ist eine andere Fallhöhe. Nochmal, weil da sitzen halt 15 andere, die es besser wissen. Und du vielleicht auch so, in dieser Stresssituation ist es jetzt auch nicht. Aber ich war damals, das war wahrscheinlich meine erste Pressekonferenz überhaupt. Und du denkst halt dann auch nicht so weit, ja wie könnte der jetzt antworten? Was du ja normalerweise im Interview, wenn du vorbereitest, das machst. Was wird der wohl antworten? Wie könnte ich ihm entgegnen? Machst du auf der Pressekonferenz nicht. Ich war ja damals einfach nur froh, den Finger, ich war damals, weil ich mir in die Hose gemacht habe, den Finger überhaupt zu heben.
Ja, genau, das kommt ja dazu.
Und dann kann das halt passieren, ja. Keine Ausrede für einen Journalisten, der das seit 13 Jahren macht, der weiß es besser. Ist schon klar, aber ich hätte es damals auch besser wissen können.
Ja gut, aber so ist das. Und dann muss Malia auch reagieren auf das, was passiert. Ich war bei der letzten Pressekonferenz Thomas Tuchel nach dem Spiel gegen Hoffenheim. Das war das erste Spiel, wo ich akkreditiert war. Das heißt, Tuchel kennt mich gar nicht, er kennt mich jetzt auch danach nicht. Aber, und ich wollte eine Frage zur Besetzung der Doppel-Sechs sprechen und zu den unterschiedlichen Aufgabenverteilungen. Und vor mir stellt Florian Plettenberg, of all people, eine Frage zur Doppel-Sechs, natürlich mit der Anschlussfrage muss jetzt Palinja kommen. Also natürlich komplett anderer Einfallswinkel. Und da habe ich dann aber während der Antwort auch kurz überlegt, ok, muss ich mir jetzt ganz spontan noch eine komplett andere Frage überlegen, die ja auch nicht total bescheuert sein sollte, oder traue ich mich jetzt einfach zu sagen, ja, also ich möchte jetzt nochmal aus einem taktischen Grund über die Doppel-Sechs sprechen, bin einfach bei der Frage geblieben, viel zu kompliziert gestellt. Antwort war quasi völlig belanglos, aber ja, so was passiert dann eben auch. Wir haben uns ein bisschen verquatscht, Yogi, und das, obwohl wir ja noch gar nicht fertig sind. Wir müssen ja noch MVP, Unsung Hero und Moment des Spieltags oder der letzten Wochen besprechen. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob du da schon was mitgebracht hast, ansonsten kannst du es dir bestimmt auch jetzt noch spontan überlegen. Hättest du einen MVP für mich?
Ehrlich gesagt Kevin de Bruyne, ich glaube, ich musst du da nehmen. Der wertvollste Spieler im Sinne von Basketball ist ja immer, wer macht bei einem Team den größten Unterschied. Das war an diesem Wochenende Kevin de Bruyne. Jürgen Klopp hat ja gesagt, Kevin de Bruyne macht sich warm und das ganze Land fängt an zu zittern. Er hatte recht, es war genauso. Und vor allem, der war schon mal mehr in Form. Du merkst, dass der noch leicht eingerostet ist. Und das macht das Ganze noch viel dramatischer, ehrlich gesagt.
Ok, da können wir uns ja auf was freuen. Gibt es einen Unsung Hero für dich? Ich habe zum Beispiel neulich gelesen, aber du kannst natürlich auch was komplett anderes nehmen. Aber wie Bournemouth seine Saison so ein bisschen gedreht hat, ist ja durchaus bemerkenswert. Also aktuell jetzt Tabellen Mittelfeld, 25 Punkte haben aus den letzten sechs Spielen vier Siege und einen Unentschieden geholt.
Ja, da würde ich genau auch einen Spieler nehmen, Dominic Solenki. Er ist momentan einer der besten Stürmer der Liga. Ich muss nachschauen, wie viele Saisontore er hat. Aber der ist momentan – bei dem hieß es ja, er ist bei zwölf Saisontoren. Da hieß es ja im Endeffekt, der ist total durch Fehleinkauf von Liverpool damals verpflichtet, die ersten 30 Spiele, glaube ich, habe ich mal aufgeschrieben, hat er gar nicht getroffen oder so. Dann die zweite Liga mit runter, da auch jetzt nicht signifikant gewesen am Anfang. Und jetzt plötzlich ist er momentan einer der besten Stürmer der Liga, muss man ganz klar sagen, in den letzten Wochen vor allem gerade gekommen. Richtig gut Lauf. Dementsprechend würde ich sagen, das ist momentan einer, der wahrscheinlich, ja, muss Anzang Hero sein, weil im Endeffekt, glaube ich, hat den nicht mal überhaupt jemand auf der Karte. Viele werden sagen, wer ist das? Also der jetzt nicht unbedingt jede Woche Premier League schaut, muss ihn auch nicht kennen, weil Bournemouth jetzt auch nicht das glänzendste Team ist, insgesamt von der Größe des Klubs. Dementsprechend würde ich den auf jeden Fall nehmen. Also den sich mal anschauen, ist momentan wirklich auf jeden Fall lohnenswert.
Und damit haben wir Bournemouth auch noch kurz abgehandelt. Das freut mich auch. Und was war der Moment der letzten Wochen oder auch des letzten Spieltags für dich?
Ja, auch das, glaube ich, war wirklich Kevin de Bruyne. Also es ist zwar doof, das jetzt wieder zu verwenden, aber es ist, glaube ich, der Moment gewesen, auch wenn ich nochmal nachgeschaut letztens so, was so die Aufrufzahlen waren und so. Also das ist schon um die Welt gegangen, dass der zurück ist. Und die Art und Weise, wie es passiert ist. Aber wenn ich wirklich den Moment runterbrechen müsste, dann wäre es wahrscheinlich echt diese Vorlage am Schluss nochmal. Und wie City da zurückgekommen ist, auch mit der… Also Oskar Bob, den muss man auch erstmal so machen. Das, glaube ich, war wirklich der Moment, muss man sagen, glaube ich, des letzten Spieltags. Der ja auch, muss man auch sagen, der ist jetzt zerpflückt. So viele Spiele waren jetzt nicht. Dementsprechend ist es jetzt auch eine kleine Grundgesamtheit, aber das war schon der Moment.
Jogi, vielen, vielen Dank. Das hat, wie immer, große Freude gemacht. Danke, dass du mit dabei warst.
Sehr, sehr gerne. Ich danke.
Und euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, danke ich für die Aufmerksamkeit. Ihr könnt mal gucken, auf Rasenfunk.de ist es jetzt wieder losgegangen. Wir haben Schwerpunkt zum 1. FC Köln gemacht. Wir haben natürlich den letzten Bundesligaspieltag aufbereitet. Und es gibt ein Tribüngespräch zur Entwicklung des Rasenfunks. Und da erzählen wir unter anderem, warum wir den Kiosk einstellen. Im Kiosk gibt es jetzt 30% Rabatt auf alles. Wir müssen unser Lager leer räumen. Warum wir das machen, erfahrt ihr im Tribüngespräch. Und einkaufen könnt ihr aber unter kiosk.rasenfunk.de. So ist die URL. Man sollte sich nicht nebenher noch Notizen für die Show Notes machen. Denn ich pack den Link in die Show Notes. Liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, danke für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Bleibt gesund, bis bald hier im Rasenfunk. Der Rasenfunk lebt von euren Beiträgen.